oh and so
on this episode I answer questions in
front of hundreds of my friends
this is
Gary B did you see D Rock's new opening
he's got something really good there'll
be none of that dunked on [ __ ] I'm just
gonna go right into it he's gonna have
to deal with me that's all I got my
name's Julie Fisher here with my twin
brother from Chicago and hold on Jimmy
shut the [ __ ] up I didn't even start the
show yet but he's got a mic what's going
on confuses [ __ ]
no worries Jimmy my bad
Alex the [ __ ] are you doing no was it
Zach what the [ __ ] are we good now can
get your [ __ ] together together all
right
not quite dick all right
here we go that's how we roll you guys
ready oh he's an aggressive man hello
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 100 of the ask gary vee
show
thank you so Boehner nation hundreds of
your family members have slept from all
over the place as a matter of fact when
you get into the questions I know
majority of your local because this was
definitely not worth slepping that far
for but some of you did it some of you
did it so I appreciate it I appreciate
so make sure you tell me where you're
from when you ask your question please
tell me who you are we are here not too
far from vaynermedia we're gonna do this
outside in the park was the original
plan which is why we had an open RSVP
until somebody with a half a brain came
up to me is like you know you need a
permit if you have more than a couple of
people at the park I'm like [ __ ] okay we
scrambled Gansevoort hooked us up thank
you so much we're here on the rooftop of
the Gansevoort hotel not far from Vayner
media in New York City and really
episode 100 you could have debated a lot
of different formats but the concept is
quite simple my friends my audience my
family is here they're gonna ask some
questions I'm gonna answer them and
we're gonna go as long and as hard as we
can so thank you so much please clap it
up for yourselves because you mean a lot
to me I know intimately know somewhat
have interacted a ton online with and a
bunch of new faces well that means a ton
to be so I think we should get right
into the show so let's do it
are you guys ready now back there there
you go all right let's do it
starting all the way in the back what
happened in Jimmy let's go with jibt
what Jimmy Jimmy got screwed I thought
she was gonna be Jimmy are you good
you're good Jimmy all right all right
all right Gary I wanna say thank you so
much
my name is Vlad I run a restaurant
Astoria Queens called miracle cows okay
it's a trademark spot so there's ways of
growing up in about three years
funny that every time I I reach a hurdle
I wake up and you answer it somehow so I
really appreciate that you're doing that
so every day kind of helped me grow our
business grow what I'm having probably
right now is that we're growing and each
part of the restaurant the kitchen for
bartending crew they became a gang you
don't love the project so much so every
time I bring somebody new you start
hating them there's gonna be a funny
[ __ ] show there's no India in this
mix go ahead keep going
so you've got a hazing restaurant keep
going guys this is Alfredo he's joining
our crew teaching what you know and
let's go because I want to grow so
instead of helping me you know grow a
[ __ ] Shep let me let me jump in on
right here because blood we need more
than one question answered on the show
you know and I think I referenced this
either in a keynote or recently or maybe
in one of the shows where I talked about
one of the things that really when I
started vaynermedia I was obsessed with
this issue because it was something that
was a huge problem at Wine Library at
Wine Library we also grew very quickly
grew from like 10 to 150 people and the
biggest problem I had was I don't know
if they haze them they weren't hazing
them they were just making their
judgment immediately like literally
every employee for like two years within
two days everybody in the company was
like a Ricky McGee sucks crap right like
like and by the way this was a company
Wine Library that had no training no
onboarding like literally you showed up
and you're like go right and then you
hit right so very easy
professional courtesy respect bring out
the lad the way I fixed that at Wine
Library was I sat down everybody
individually when it got to a place
where it was not pavel to me anymore
one by one and I told him right to their
face that they if they weren't part of
the solution of fixing my issue they
weren't gonna be there and that was
probably the first time I gave any of
them negative feedback because we were
growing everything was great they were
making more money levy thing was great
and I told them right to their face and
then Vlad and this is the tricky one
then I fired a couple of them right in
their mouths flat fire someone that's it
black glad no more Mike I've got to
answer some questions I love you no more
glad you're out next let's just fire
someone glad she's all right let's keep
it going my name is Jenny Fisher from
New York I'm with my brothers from
Chicago I love it our question has to do
with him and I are working on a bunch of
different projects that's already a
problem starting a bar and I just get a
guy does it have a digital agency and
then new construction consulting real
good stuff I love it our question is
working with AJ yassine brothers in in a
business together yes could you speak to
a specific example where you guys have
had to overcome that family relationship
working through a business challenge so
you know with AJ I've had a lot less
problems that I did with my dad for a
lot of different reasons different
personalities different parts of the
equation I was the number two coming up
in Wine Library I'm the number one with
vaynermedia I'm 11 years older than AJ
we started an eBay business when he was
9 or 10 so we thought you know he
negotiated like that business I remember
starting off as like 70/30 but then like
one day in he told me it needed to be
50/50 and so like we fought that out and
like had our fisticuff moments then you
know I think I don't you know the truth
is Vayner was easy because one the big
decision that could have caused a lot of
problems was addressed immediately which
was we made the company 50/50 and even
though I had all the leverage and I was
in the market and the company was built
a lot of my brand I thought it was
important to start the relation
ship off in the right foot and make us
equal partners the truth is AJ has uh AJ
is very self-aware in the same way that
I am and he's as time has gone on
recognizes you know the disproportionate
value that I bring he really does like
he's been a perfect partner to me AJ is
the one in our relationship as we are
looking at different business deals the
fund and all the future things he was
the one that came to me and said hey bro
I think that you should have more of the
action as we go forward in X Y & Z that
takes a lot of humility that takes a lot
of self-awareness that takes a lot of
things and so I think you know we've had
our fisticuffs right like you know we
had an argument of he was convinced that
clients would not pay us a fourth of
what they're paying now for a monthly
retainer commenced and and obviously me
winning that debate has helped me to
have some equity with him you know but
he brings a ton of stuff and I've
referenced it throughout the 500
questions I've answered on this show
he's brought a lot of value to me he's
massively mature for his age and in a
lot of ways it you know not only please
the straight man in our relationship but
he just he's also got magic and stuff
like he's a perfect dude I'm super fun
he's getting married in three weeks and
and my beards upset about that but at
the end of the day you know what it's
crazy
we're now five and a half almost six
years into this we're actually six years
into this venture we've really not had a
blowout blowout you know we're good at
like we're close to like did you guys
see the basketball video like that's
where we fight as you saw in that one
little clip like on when we're on the
same team we're really good and so we
have our moments but I'm sure the 11
year you know age difference all the
circumstances right the circumstances
make the the pudding as I like to say
and so like though I've never said the
circumstances make the pudding ever
before in my life I've never said it but
the circumstances have everything to do
with it so I don't know if our
relationship can project things to you
but I will say this being the bigger man
I've said it a bunch in every situation
always works whoever and you if one of
you takes the lead as
the person when you argue that first
jimson says I love you bro and like [ __ ]
this or whatever like it will force the
other one to start doing it as well
eventually over time I can promise you
that because I sure did that a shitload
as my dad and finally after 15 [ __ ]
years he started playing that game out
so I think you should consider that cool
let's clap it up for that question why
are you doing Gary I'm from Edison New
Jersey your hometown I love that what's
your name bro Alex Romero I love it
developer I'm currently working that
called hack which is for happy hours
okay but the big question I have for you
is more related to a billboard marketing
are you behind the tongue hashtag town
shady I wish that I could take credit
for that Tom Brady hazing billboard but
I'm not but thank you so much for
bringing up that question so that we
were able to talk about it here today I
want the loudest clap for that man
except for tattoo Patriot fans here
let's keep it going
hey I'm Jen live with um from New York
originally but here with a team of
community managers from Philly and my
brother from New York loved it um thank
you so much for the show first of all
it's awesome we freaking love it thank
you
so once asked if well I know you hate
automation but yes yes so big to the
point where you're scaling your
community so much that you critical
Tommy what how do you do how do you Shen
right that's what you said your name Jen
why is it critical to automate like if
you're getting thousands of emails a day
of registration annually right back okay
okay got it you know there's a big guys
let me and this is why this show is
great let me redefine this there's a big
difference between automating your human
interaction versus automatic automating
a signup process or something that can
and is acceptable to be automated like
for example I think it was today I just
saw it somewhere my stream like did the
president United States sign up today
like right like like I think he said the
tweet was on Twitter I think Barack
Obama finally signed up in the tweet
was like now I'm finally really here
there was a video made six years ago
that you can see where people got mad at
me because I said that wasn't really
Barack Obama tweeting on his behalf and
that was [ __ ] up because everybody was
mad at Britney Spears for like a day for
not doing it and having her manager like
and everybody was all about Obama and
down on Britney at the time I was like
[ __ ] this Britney's back baby
so I jumped on I wanted backup Britney
and I jumped in and made a video I was
like do you think Barack's really doing
this and everybody's mad at me so Jenna
I think I think when you need to
recognize is there's plenty of
circumstances where you need to automate
as long as you're not making protect
like if your automation email when
somebody's signing up is like hey Jack
this is Rick really now you're getting
into that level of like trying to fake
the funk but automation is fine in a lot
of places not just I just don't want
people automating their human
interaction or making pretend it to them
you know people get pumped with a
celebrity replies to them that like mean
something to them and when they find out
that that's like Ricky the PM of that
person they get disappointed and that
takes equity away it's it's just not
authentic you should only do so much
yeah what else was that it
well no meaning I don't want a second
question but like are we now aligned
like was the did I clarified that
conversation that totally clarifies it
thank you
awesome well that's tremendous all right
let's clap it up hell yeah it's on that
Gary my name is Julian I'm 20 years old
and from Warsaw Poland I love it and
Julian are you the one that way I was
tweeting with today yes sir
and so you didn't even know what's going
on tonight no and then we tweeted yeah
and then you showed up yeah Big Ups to
Poland Baby Gap
that's the ROI of Twitter [ __ ] faces
alright sorry I can't hear [ __ ] go ahead
over I know didn't fly from Poland 20
minutes ago dick I get it I got it start
over start off I have a health care
company okay that's focused on
eliminating obesity in America and I'm
meeting with all those of you seize and
they look at me and I look like I'm 12
years old and they're like you know what
the [ __ ] do you know
yep so I explained the problem they're
like oh yeah that's really good idea
like we really like that but leave it to
the grown-ups and I was going oh [ __ ]
you and your receding hairline dude I'm
losing hair so watch yourself God so so
how do I get like respect for them and
actually make them see eye to eye like
I'm not you know a little tackling a big
problem you know look I think I think
the truth is that's interesting to me
because I would tell you like I have no
empathy for you because this is the
greatest era of all time of kids getting
disproportional respect because we've
seen technology grow and you know I'm I
was looking at the 30 and 40 year-olds
in this audience who were like debt we
wish we had any we wish we were allowed
to do anything but go grab the coffee 20
years ago so I promise you like you're
getting way more respect the fact that a
VC is willing to see you is like way
advanced compared to where it was five
or ten or fifteen years ago I would say
this though and look you need to raise
money right like you're not going to see
them to go see their receding hairline
you're going because you want their
money yes I want to align you on some
respect factor you're going to ask
somebody for their money right so you
know it we're in a place now where
money's flowing so freely but I would
also keep that chip on your shoulder
because that's great I love that the
best thing to do and I've said this
before in the show is sell to people
that are willing to buy to me the second
I feel any indication that somebody's
not interested like I'll give me a good
example if I went on a VC pitch and it
was allocated for 45 minutes and if you
sniffed out that they're just like
they're out there like out I would cut
the meaning short I want that 30 minutes
back right so I would
tell you to sell to people that are
interested versus trying to get somebody
and sell it to them I'm never selling to
anybody but the market that's attract
I'm selling to you guys you're attracted
to this content I appreciate that I'm
not trying to convince anybody else that
this is right I'm just gonna go out and
prove it you know so I would I would
first it sounds like you need money I've
never gone out and raised money I just
do [ __ ] make money and then go back and
tell you I told you so right that you
know and so for me it sounds like you
need dollars cool but money is easy go
find the people that want to find their
Polish Mark Zuckerberg take their money
and go and execute use that than you for
seven days in New York so that'll but I
know you mean yeah I get it but like
like like I'm not sure what that even
meant meaning like really like going
into a bar where they let me in because
I'm 20 right I already get like shut
down right we're all the networking
events are so I actually was standing
outside of like Wall Street firms and
like hitting up people I think your
strategy was [ __ ] up then right like
well I mean there's two ways to look at
what I mean your strategy's not [ __ ]
up if you if you hustled to get to New
York right from Poland to try to raise
money then that's awesome but then I
wouldn't be what was me about that like
dude I [ __ ] worked 19 hours a day
like ever like like everybody's got
struggles what's that I work 20 cool I
work 21 so I here's what I think I think
that you've clearly got hustle right and
like I guess let's go backwards let lets
make it to ask the Polish kids show what
what are you what do you need right now
money yes cool monies I think money's
shockingly easy so what I would tell you
is I would have before I came to New
York and knocked on doors I would have
used the internet new thing and I would
have emailed people hit them up on
Twitter done different things to try to
have much warmer meetings in place how
many meetings did you have in place when
you got here I had about something so
it's good I mean so how did those go
well but they looked at me
20 years old and said this is a way too
complex problem to solve for somebody I
disagree I think that's what you want to
think they thought well I mean they told
me and I said yeah but by the way I bet
you that they said that to you because a
lot of people are bad at giving critical
advice they probably just used that as
an excuse because I promise you I know
every [ __ ] VC in the game and they're
pumped to give a 20 year old money they
just want to give it to something they
believe in
cool man good luck Thanks this live
thing okay keep it go I like it keep it
going
I mean India's great now but like the
real person here I love it
hey business Tony you bow and speaking
to follow up and Jen's questions before
your follow on Instagram I'm forever
indebted possibly thanks man I'm humbled
um so my question is Wednesday I'll be
on stage for the first time at a
conference speaking and your keynotes
are particularly special and unique but
do you have any advice on how to go
about yeah I'm getting or how about
giving it I think the reason my keynotes
have worked for me is I've just stuck to
what to the way I communicate right I
think people overthink presentations
they're stressful and there's a lot you
know first of all look it came natural
to me I didn't know like the first talk
I ever gave I was like 30-something all
right like wasn't like oh I'm gonna be a
public speaker they come natural to me
right but I I think I think there's
another there's a real strong reason
they've worked for me and that's because
I just talk about what I know the reason
I don't need slides the reason I feel
very comfortable doing the askgaryvee
show is i stay in my lane i'm punked by
the way I'm hoping today I can answer
not sure right you know like you gotta
you guys saw it recently with the new
Facebook integration just haven't used
it yet don't have a thought like so I
would say you know and it's back to the
great question for the 20 year old from
Poland right which is like you just have
to you know it's the same game which is
like stick to what you know like I look
by the way that interaction was super
fun for me cuz I believe he's got a shot
I think you need to focus on the plus
side not the down side so I think you
just need to
focus on what you know like you got
asked to speak the problem is a lot of
people are faking the funk with speaking
right a lot of people are I'm an expert
before ever doing anything and so
they're they're stuck because they've
got a like talk above their execution
right and so as long as you stick to
what your execution is even if it's even
if you've been build and build at a
higher level than you even think you are
just stick to what you know walking with
humility the reason I often start my
keynotes as you've all seen with how
many people here know who I am I always
know that 90% of the room doesn't and it
always freaks out the 10% that does
right but the world's big and there's a
lot of stuff out there and so I would
walk in with humility I would talk about
what you know and I would communicate
the way you're most comfortable in
communicating I'd be crippled right now
if I had a read cue cards because it's
not comfortable to me I can barely read
and like that would be a problem Kuhlman
I'm noticing a lot of people not
clapping
all right hey guys what's going on it's
Darrell
hey Darrell are you doing tremendous
thank you
co-founder of toast which is okay I want
to know what's actually about the
economy
okay I want to make sure you and I are
aligned on the sharing economy term
because a lot of people are throwing it
out in different ways give me some
examples of some companies or some
executions why do you why do you find
Buber as a sharing a company or rezi is
where you're about to go okay breather
cool got it got it I see it eating up
everything so and here's why I think
that human inefficiency is the most
interesting biggest upside market I also
know that people pay for time this is a
theme that I've clearly pounded in these
hundred shows and I'm glad because it's
gonna happen and people can understand
mean we what blows my mind is looking at
the level of income you need to make to
actually buy back time and the numbers
low you know this isn't about making a
hundred thousand years isn't about
making a million a year people that are
you know are being very careful about
what they spend every dollar on are
willing to get an uber are willing to
you know use post mates or instead it's
really time man telling you time as an
asset that we are all increasingly every
day starting to value more and more
because we're being pounded by so much
and because every second you live is one
second closer to your death right and I
think that people actually
subconsciously understand that you know
time becomes more and more valuable I
mean it's crazy to me you know you you
know I would always hear older people
say like us you get older time goes
faster [ __ ] is real like
half this here is gone what the [ __ ]
Riley like like it's intense and so I
think I think anything that software
connecting to individuals where there's
a supply and demand situation at hand
d-roc totally what to do where there's a
supply and demand situation at hand is
always going to be interesting right
like cuz there's so many people
interested in alligator there's just
it's brings so much value save me time
or do something I don't want to do like
that's the thing for me right like I
don't want to put that list he's like
put that picture up in the living room
[ __ ] no have no interest don't want to
do it can't do it really well don't want
to do it super pumped to open my app
handy man get the [ __ ] over here you
know and so I think there should be a
ton of that thank you you got it hello
sup Gary over to your right senior man
Cheers my name is John Henry I'm serial
entrepreneur now just coming off my
first exit and now I'm running an
accelerator so it kind of puts me in an
odd position cuz my first company my
success is predicated on how well I
execute it yes and now it's predicated
on how well my companies get to execute
by the way shoutout to Sean I went to
vayner/rse last week you wanna stop by
great um but can you give me some advice
on what to focus on with my companies to
make sure that they go out there and
kill it yeah listen I really struggled
with this transition from being the
entrepreneur at Wine Library to
investing after I made the first three
good investments Facebook Twitter and
Tumblr where I was like really just
trying to make money and I was like
these are the best companies let me when
I then started investing for real which
was interesting I got Dumber as I
started investing for real the biggest
thing that you need to be careful of is
recognizing you're not executing it I
made a ton of investments based on
things that I knew would work I just
didn't realize oh crap the jockey can
screw it up so you've heard me a lot say
I bet on jockeys a lot of times not just
the horse you need to be careful that
these companies aren't just great on
paper with like the idea you have to
believe in the entrepreneur it's all
operations and execution
every idea is good in theory
so I think the biggest thing you need to
look out for is you need to be auditing
the individuals not necessarily the idea
who yeah thanks for being here that's a
huge huge flaw for people that make the
shift from being operator to investor
you're imposing yourself into the game
hi my name is thank you so much yes yes
how similar because if it's competitive
to something I've invested and I want
you out of business
God have got it so yeah look I you know
first time protects the CEO of
Misha's activities name Lizzy Vaynerchuk
I know I know my role but of course I'd
love to check it out and I'm thrilled
and thank you and I appreciate the
hustle which is the biggest reason I'll
probably check it out and so is there a
questionnaire were you pitching your
product
yeah you're really getting into very
granular terms
I appreciate I'm sure everybody who's
watching this now can see and so I think
yeah I'll definitely get at home I'm uh
I appreciate the hustle
I love the pitch and I I'm going to the
Mets game tonight for a business meeting
as some of you know and I'll definitely
get it home don't worry I'll give it the
stunwin
because that makes me laugh all right
let's move on questions
that's hardcore pitch hey what's up Gary
my name is Jackie
jab me all that much for that right hook
yeah yeah got pain attention always
brother but my name is Chad I'm a
founder of a company called Brickfest
live we run live leggo events that
attract tens of thousands of people yeah
that's cool so our mission is to inspire
educate and entertain you know the next
generation of Lego builders because you
know cuz that stuff cuz it's a big
[ __ ] industry yeah and and why is
your brain sort of problem something no
question which is what we're all doing
yeah my question is actually more about
what you do with this show and the
people that you have around you to
support it how much of their time to
spend on you as opposed to other things
all their time is spent on me the entire
the entire team that's Mixon is all part
of brand Gary team all of it
so that some of them have worked at
vaynermedia within vaynermedia before
and we're pluck Steve you know India you
know Alex plucked out of the machine
onto team and others have been you know
cold hired just for exact and roogie
rock Stefan for it
because we started actually on a YouTube
channel yep where you know all the
production was us yes and and that's how
Wine Library TV was but ours but with
this I have so much more scale and as
you can tell what I'm doing is I'm
producing so much more content off of
the show
for medium and all the distribution so
and and I'm learning through these guys
as they're actually now doing the tea
rocks today everything andrás meter
counting India's taking photos what I'm
learning is what does the production
company look like for a human being
right which I think [ __ ] rad you know
and so I and I and I think that there's
you got understand there's you know as
well as I'm doing there are a lot more
successful people wealthier like there
are that top three percent of celebrity
that are way grossly overpaying their PR
people their managers their boy from
around the way that they're taking care
of like all that stuff that I think
creates a really interesting business
model the future because I do
leave and you know this every single
person is a media company I believe that
cold and so not only am i producing not
only am i giving back to a community
that's been in place and growing but I'm
getting to learn the infrastructure of
how I would scale this if I wanted to do
it for LeBron awesome cool let's keep it
going hey Chris Green firmeza juice hey
Chris thanks let's go you could make any
company successful and I know you
believe in we all believed it but when
you can do so many different things when
your hustle can turn into so many
different things with so many
opportunities today 2015 how do you
choose what to do and what's your
greatest opportunity cost to do what
you're doing this is the part that I'm
not great at you know many around me
would argue that I've done a poor job in
selecting opportunity costs because of
the earlier question to the gal that
pitched all the stuff of you know I'm
playing such a long my vulnerability now
I think I said on one episode but I'm
not sure my vulnerability is that I was
too patient and I left the prime years
on the table by giving back too much by
leveraging too much by doing
non-scalable things too much and so it's
something you know it turned 40 in
November and much like when I turned 30
and freaked out at Wine Library and
started Wine Library TV I definitely I
think I'm forcing the narrative because
I think it's convenient but I'm
definitely feeling weird I'm not I'd be
lying if I wasn't I've been spending a
ton of time on it you know and I'm sure
I did I don't really recall this but I
remember but I actually do recall it I
remember thinking like alright thirty to
forty is gonna be the years where I lay
down the foundation to buy the New York
Jets right and so you know definitely
been
you know forty to fit like this this is
it right and I'm sure when I get to 50
I'm like just this is really it you know
but I gotta be honest with you like I'm
not sure that I'm the best guy for this
answer because the truth is I
I like non-scalable things I love doing
stuff like this like you understand at
some level and I think people eventually
will figure this out about me and I
think a lot of people here probably do
recognize it i disproportionately like
people which will then probably
ultimately not allow me to maybe squeeze
out every dollar but I'm still gonna be
much happier for like this show like I'm
gonna watch this show like let me just
talk to myself you look terrible you
know that was me talking mine here old
self like these things like it's funny
when I come across somebody tweeting out
like an episode of Wine Library TV for
like 2006 like I do a ton of stuff that
I'm black and white don't look like the
smart opportunity cosplay but they're
the things that make me happy as a human
being and just hustling for the cash of
it we're buying the Jets is only one
part of the equation for me and so I
think you know from a business sense I
leave a lot on the table from a life
sense
I'm happy with my allocation of my time
I'm happy that I get together with
former employees that I love so much
even though everybody around me will say
we need those 15 minutes for these 700
other things that need to happen
I don't care and so I think that you
know I think the way I judge it is how
it feels in my stomach and my heart not
my brain
Chris made the Lego thing dude Wow
where are we when are we showing we'll
show that tomorrow what yeah okay insane
way to see this guy's what he made was
in sane anyway you should talk to the
other you know the other Lego dudes dude
you need to see what he made it's sick
alright let's move it
I love Legos by the way it's nice hey
Gary my name is Joe pick your uncle
Stalin first off I want to say you know
props to Gary you just bring us like
this energy and this like inspiration to
is I'm here dude I'm right here
Thank You Man thank you I know I know
it's very meta up in here first though I
spent a little bit of time while working
out Wall Street financial industry and I
know that industry is kind of like
trapped and like a lot of old ways of
doing things and I think they're getting
really hit hard by a lot of the
electronic trading platforms but on the
same token I think there's a lot of room
for life they want communications with
your your fa and your broker and just
was someone coming from that industry
how would you apply your minutes and
your teachings to something like that
industry so you know it's funny to be
watching you ask that question with
Mitch Stan and a few say I'm right in
front of you who I think is executed you
know literally my answer to your
question is go hang out with Mitch for
15 minutes and have a coffee after this
I think it's super easy technology is
the gateway drug to human interaction
period end of story I believe that like
she's like we will be robots eventually
I firmly believe that I I'm not joking I
I fully believe that now it's in my own
mind I really hope I don't see it cuz
it's weird like I think of like brain
twist like it's crazy to think that like
I mean hardcore robots like straight up
you know like but but
until then I think that there's plenty
of room for that I think the problem is
there's too many old school folks that
are like nothing beats a handshake and a
one-to-one meeting and they don't use
the technology it's much like the way I
branded you know Andy's sitting here
Andy does a lot of the quant you know
growth hacking like build the audience
stuff like I think that I relied too
much on just brand and content if I
could do Wine Library TV all over again
the show would be 50x the success it was
because I did nothing right from a tech
standpoint distribution
it was just word-of-mouth PR it just
crushed quality content wise but you
know with technology in place you should
use it and so I think that of course
there's human interaction of course
there's content like this that can play
in every sector obviously there's legal
ramifications in that world but all of
them have but I think I think the more
interesting question is I think there's
far more of the reverse to be honest
with you I think there's far more some
more of the emerging trend of people
that are still in power places that
don't realize there's tech that can
scale them and bring them to a different
level well thank you yeah you got it
well I don't know I have to go to a
thing cause you know what but I don't
get it it's only five eleven oh you want
me to mingle so I think my plan is as
you guys know I'm going to this meeting
my plan is to probably just gently I
think it would be maybe we could start a
quick hashtag like hash tag like here at
askgaryvee or something or then that's
fine just do it here at a scare of you
don't [ __ ] try to change it that's
what it is and and I think you guys
should talk to each other go somewhere
and then I think I'm gonna try when I'm
done with the business part of my
meeting I'm gonna try to get back into
the city and I think I'll definitely
come by and try to high-five and say
hello and I'll take some selfies and do
that because I I think I want to answer
a couple more questions and I know a lot
of people schlepped and things of that
nature so people keep a little bit like
how about this by show of hands how many
people have to go back far away home not
that you you can't live in New York New
Jersey Connecticut or Pennsylvania
okay cool those people that raised their
hands that haven't interacted with me a
ton get your ash you can get up here
I'll try to bang out a couple of those
selfies and say hello and high five and
then the rest I'll try to see in life
sometimes alright let's keep it going
love it so I know that you work 16 17 18
hours at age 19 hour depending on who
said they work more you work more that's
right 25 hours a day [ __ ] especially
from my always how are you well I think
we have to define productive because
it's interesting to Gerrits question
right like you mean how am I actually
physically executing that many I would
argue that I'm not so outrageously
productive so I guess the first one you
know what I mean let's break it let's
break it down what is your definition of
productivity is it hustle
because every time I think about
productivity I just think about I think
results you know like when I think of
productivity I think about results and
then I think about short term loop
results and long term results like I
feel like the askgaryvee show was a
productive venture because I'm very
humbled right now that all of you came
here today and it makes me super duper
happy right I can also think it's
productive because multiple companies
have now paid me instead of going in
publicly speaking because I can't make
every event they've actually paid me for
a custom version of the askgaryvee show
so that was productive I get paid a lot
of money for that that seemed pretty
cool I like that I also think it's
productive because my next book that
comes out in February is gonna be called
askgaryvee and the home thematic around
it is that so that's gonna be productive
so there's a lot of different ways to it
depends on how one defines productivity
number one to me it's the output and so
you guys heard insight into another
thing right this seven person team is
giving me a blueprint that I'm pushing
against to try to figure out a bigger
business model
I mean look my marketing activity for
Wine Library
was productive because I grew my family
business to a big business it also
became the output of my learnings that
became the foundation of my personal
brand which became the beacon to
building the fastest growing social
digital agency ever right like so like
I'm always I'm doing things that people
feel are not scalable in the moment that
I find to be very scalable if you're
willing to look at them in a 5 to 10
year window got it like was it
productive for me to take that meeting
with Chris deci when he randomly emailed
me and said hey will you take this
meeting and I said sure which then led
to a 15-minute I'm just gonna pay
forward to this kid moment which I love
to do because you never know when this
time I didn't know because it led to he
being one of the early employees of
Buddy Media which was a company Mike
Lazaro had and I will tell you that that
led to free office space at wine lot for
vaynermedia when we started it in the
conference room at Buddy Media it also
led to me giving a quote to Mike Lazaro
for a buddy media where he gave me
warrants to his company which later sold
for a billion dollars to Salesforce so I
made seven figures on a quote to a
website so I called that productive for
that 15-minute meeting but it also led
to a friendship that has become one of
the core friendships for Lizzie and I
and this Saturday night I got to spend
time with a very small group for us
oldest son's Bar Mitzvah and that speech
to the son gave and the speech that Mike
gave is something that is engraved in my
heart for the rest of my life
I called that productive but then
there's a billion 15-minute meetings
that I take where the kids a piece of
[ __ ] and nothing good happened so when
you play it in a net-net game I think
that people are overthinking their
at-bats right and I think intent matters
I think people are trying to be too
technically sound to they're not
allowing for serendipity and serendipity
is where all the magic is my friends all
of it
so hey you hear me yeah I hear you I see
you I love the Mario shirt
very nice Stefan you got the Mario shirt
okay should I talk yes you should talk
country of Georgia and I know you love
wine so you know of course I read about
you a lot
hmm and what I like is that and you one
of your videos you say one is better
than the zero I won't be slower than I
always do this so I think that's one of
the best videos yeah Stefan let's hear
for step yes I say I'm only in the food
business today
okay and I believe in healthy so my
question is if I target New York City as
a health features and health eating like
CD in the future it might be right I
know I will have one or more followers
one is still better than zero but should
I go in this and show that it creates
some shows social media content in that
terms and which it should be like video
or deals or blogging or stuff what do
you see I understand what you're saying
let's let's take a step back hold on to
the mic what what are you actually doing
what's the business actually new because
that will dictate whether more this
startup with my friends and I'm working
I'm working in the restaurant so got it
what's the what's the product so the
product is Georgian recipe will
modernize for American market
interesting in the retail market is it
is it an actual like yeah food it's a
food you know you yep it's like a hummus
yeah like hummus but you're much
different we don't we're much better
than Hamid Khan this
okay so are you asking about marketing
that product no I'm asking about social
media term like should I go into social
media actually and create some social
come to the both healthy you know will
it be success no you should make content
about your product your product well
that's it
there's no not of course you just
[ __ ] ask me about some [ __ ] food
[ __ ] and in New York your product focus
on making content around your product
and around the lifestyle of that product
but but not for the sake of New York
City health enthusiasts right me spec
you're so small like you can't worry
about going that abstract nobody know
there's not a single person here that
knows what the [ __ ] you're talking about
they're like Georgian dip you mean
Georgia like Atlanta know the former
[ __ ] Soviet Union [ __ ] you know so
you know what it means so like so like
you have to understand like nobody
understands you have to educate it's
kind of like you know I don't know if
this was a you know I left Russia a
young but like when I was growing up we
ate a ton of pomegranates right but
nobody in America eight pomegranates in
the 80s like my friends would come over
to play with Legos and Apple you know
it's like like we a pocket for years and
years and years before palm juice came
and pomegranate became like you know a
pink berry flavor right so like I think
that you have a lot of educating to do
like I I don't know what you're talking
about and I was born in that area I
don't know I don't know what you're
talking about so I think that you need
to focus there you're going to abstract
and that's a good piece of advice for a
lot of people like way too many people
back till I said it before because it's
just so important how many people here
know who I am
ninety percent you know don't people
make way too many assumptions that they
think they're bigger than they actually
are
you know and it's fine it makes people
feel good but like for as much ego and
bravado as I have 24 hours 25 I think I
can build any business I'm always
grounded in reality I think you need to
focus on building a story around your
product you got a minute
where's chiffon okay we'll come back
here after good hey you gotta read
what's going on my name is Tom Messner
we's co-founder of a brand of vodka
called Ruth are you a Jets fan I love
the Jets you tell them truth cuz I felt
soft are you joining two offensive
lineman receivers running back no dick
because people that love a football team
know the offensive line line yes I
wanted to see um you know where do you
see the biggest opportunity for
innovation for a wine and spirits brand
in the market today so look I mean
you're going into like first of all I
like you already because that's ballsy
to go into vodka because vodkas past its
trend which actually think begins its
next opportunity to it's crowded three
it's really really financially intensive
you need money right so I think you know
I think the nice thing is this fall is
perfectly aligned to the world we live
in right like you being part of this
community that's your only prayer your
only prayer is to know what's going on
on meerkat your only prayer to know you
know to win is knowing what's going on
on Yik yak right and all these things so
I think the place to innovate is in
storytelling
it's not about huge billboards anymore
it's not about going to wholesalers and
giving them tons of dollars for their
salespeople to kick it in the store it's
about creating a groundswell but you've
got to create content and you've got to
create in relevant places you've got to
find micro influencers there's a ton to
be done but it's a tough game man it's a
real tough game it's something like this
one of the said kind of clearing out the
cave yes for all the cats but yes
something we're trying to do is just go
where other brands now 100% there's a
ton you need to become the vodka of like
well elderly Lego builders you know like
like you know you know like you're gonna
have to go super niche like EDM
influencers everybody's their dick face
what are you talking about you're
finished you're out of business max
let's go up here we're going to where
other people aren't right like EDM
that's that you're out of your mind what
do you mean one more all right
cool this is gonna be last one first of
all I just want to thank everybody for
being here
y'all gotta go see ya you never know if
it could rain at the Mets game alright
hey Gary my name is Megan sell my how
are you I'm well how are you good
alright I'm a personal trainer and a
recent grad here in the Upper East Side
of New York City yep
I have you know a lot of internship
experience I have agencies full-service
marketing agencies I love it I crave it
I want to get back into it okay now what
is a fundamental skill that you find a
lot of entry level marketers lacking
that you feel they should take advantage
of um you know it's funny it's not how I
think about it to be honest with you
it's a good question I understand where
you're going with it I'm not worried
about what you don't have
I'm more worried about what you have
better on your strengths a hundred
percent you know like like I'm not gonna
waver from this stuff right this is what
I believe in so you know I don't know
because it's not how I even process what
I want to know is you know look your
passion for craving it might just be
enough you know there's a lot of
different ways now the truth is I'm
telling people have passion so passion
and another skill more interesting
passion and two skills or but remember
skills come in two forms you went and
formed it or it naturally comes to you
right and so I think the question is
looking and I would tell you that you're
looking to get back in the game if
you're in you endo hanging about and
plot applying
vaynermedia I think what you need to do
is walk in there with the honest truths
that are you as a marketer and maybe you
went over that process through the work
ethic because this feels like something
you can control but maybe it's a DNA
thing maybe hard work is a DNA thing I
don't know you know you got to go in
there though with the truths spend all
your time talking about that and move
vote Zack as a designer sitting in front
of you had natural speed qualities as a
designer and that's why he's so great
for me because and that that's why he's
so great for me because he brings so
much value to me because we're fast
unlike Zack we need to redesign this
entire 40 page website and I need an
hour he's like cool you know like like
that you know and so like it's you know
and for other people they think that
we're crazy that it has to go through
process and triple-checked and I respect
that Bowman that's the original
they don't even fit the Bowman I love
for you got the gritty stuff
I love the basic he's flashing baseball
cards behind the guy he's totally
hacking the system I love it look the
Jordan upper that card huh so I think
that's it it's not what I'm looking for
it's you going in with what you got okay
cool man
pass the mic you have yes go ahead let's
do it d rocks can be upset go so yes sir
I'm sorry I'm just being respectful I
love you so much for what I asked you to
clap you said go [ __ ] yourself Frank
Thomas it felt like I appreciate it go
ahead what you mean Tony :
Turner me a couple of miles of the block
possible um my my son I got Michael
Corleone I got dragged back into an
industry I didn't want to get into okay
my 16 year old son in the UK who I'm
proud to call the dropouts is genetic
forget it go into direct sales industry
and yes trained I don't how many
thousands of thousands of people in it
but they were never family so it's like
the velvet cloth and the [ __ ] hammer
in the other hand yes it's a bit tougher
with the son when he said I'm saying you
know you're on of this meeting I don't
go for a bike ride
and while I'm being polite and nice and
being the good father he's on the other
side of the world
deep down I want to smash my [ __ ]
head through a window yeah where's the
balance that you've worked with um there
I never had you know what though I've
worked up and kind of parallel like I
watched my two
now and start projecting this world I
don't know man look I my big thing is
very similar to the same question he had
I mean I have no interest in imposing my
will on my kids I all I'm gonna do is
listen where you have a disconnect is if
your son's curious why it's not working
out so well or why he's not making more
or why it's not so awesome that's the
tougher conversation when you've got to
really like just splash some cold water
on him because you're going bike riding
when everybody else is going to the
sales meeting you know that to me but I
don't know I don't think I'm ready or
prepared to give advice about a child
because it's a different kind of love
it's a different kind of system I feel
great about giving advice as being the
Chuck this child I feel great about
being the sibling but for children right
now I don't know I can feel what I'm
projecting which is look my kids are
gonna be really well off and I can't
expect
I can't bake environment so I don't
expect I'm beat first of all I don't
expect anybody be as hungry as me let
alone my kids who are gonna be Upper
Eastside rich kids right so I need to
I'm not sure I know I know we have to go
I know I got it thanks you got it all
right we're getting out of here
thank you for supporting the show
question of the day what's the new thing
what are your feelings that the show
ends today you keep asking questions
someone else could have to answer them
Gary be so uh maybe I'll maybe I'll say
some words before I tape the episode I
really really appreciate everybody being
here I obviously some of you know many
of you probably know [ __ ] if you came
here you definitely know that I've done
up that I've done uh you know I never
thought that I would have another show
it didn't never really even crossed my
mind
I didn't think I'd have one show let
alone anything else and so to hit this
milestone of episode I'm sorry you can't
move with me the rock oh you couldn't
you couldn't written to hit this
milestones a lot of fun I'm really glad
I was able to uh to get here I you know
the truth is and I think a lot of you
know this like i under mentally feed off
audience and so I I would have never
gotten here if you guys didn't care
enough to watch obviously I have zero
interest in producing something and
nobody's watching that would stop me
immediately so you know it's super
cliche I always hate when people like oh
I want to thank the fans and all that
kind of [ __ ] but the truth is I only do
things for admiration and attention
because of the way my mom coddled me as
a child so I really really thank you
guys for caring and watching the show
I've really enjoyed doing it to me you
know Q&A is really the moat you know I
you know secretly I probably started
this show because I wanted to build
brand around QA because when I speak you
know as many of you know you can go to
youtube and see the spiel right I can I
mix it up depending on the audience but
my philosophies don't change at 4040 of
the 55 minutes I mean I'm sure for some
of you you watch these keynotes and if
you can get one or two new thoughts and
a different talk you like yeah there's
something different you know like so
this was a chance for me to produce a
lot of content on my current thoughts
you know I think a funny thing somebody
just tweeted I saw was like you know
meerkat didn't exist when this show
started right and so many people here
are streaming and so I thank you I'm
humbled I know it's the middle of day I
know a lot of you are hustling and
executing and doing your own thing and
for you to take time to come and support
me in this
means a lot to me and so I'm gonna keep
it very very basic I'm gonna do my intro
we're gonna walk around the rock just
texted me he's like how many questions
you want to do I'm like as many as
[ __ ] possible yeah I really I really
have nothing else to say thank you so so
much